(laughter)
- Terry.
- What's up homeboy?
- Hey what's up?
- Oh, look at this grip.
How you doing?
- I'm good, how are you?
- Oh man.
I'm gonna get right into it.
I am a fitness nut.
Oh wow.
- These are real.
- Yeah dude, this is not make believe.
- Oh my gosh, that's the size of my head.
- I am developing my own
- Okay.
- Protein shake that I think would work
for everyone.
I just want you to taste it
and see if it's going to work.
- Okay
- And, I'm gonna try a bit.
(techno music)
- I'm not mad at it.
- Yeah.
- Okay it does just straight up taste
like a chocolate milkshake.
- Yes, it's good.
- It is really good, yeah.
- That's the best protein in the world.
- Is it already working?
Oh yeah.
- It's honestly really good.
- You wanna know,
- I feel like there's
something crazy in it.
- It is delicious.
- But it tastes like a malted milkshake.
- You wanna know what
the secret ingredient is?
- I'm scared.
Oh God.
- I don't know if I wanna know.
- No, no.
- Depends on where you live.
What do you-
- No.
- What do you think?
- Oh no, it was a trap.
- I, son of a bitch, I knew
this was gonna happen today.
(laughter)
- It's good though.
- Are they live?
- Uh uh,
no, they're already blended up.
What's in there?
- Crickets.
- Listen man.
You know what those are.
- They're bugs.
- They're crickets.
- No, they're not bugs, it's crickets.
- Terry Crews how could you do this to me,
you don't even know me.
- What do you mean,
listen I'm sipping with you baby.
- Okay, cheers.
Wait, wait.
- Now that I know what
it is, it's so bizarre.
- Do I have any leg in my teeth?
If you get past the stigma,
do you know how many people
you could feed in the world?
- Oh, all of them.
- We just solved the world.
It's not a real product so I'm sorry.
- What?
What the heck?
- I don't know, I have no
idea, I'm just kidding.
No, I'm not really selling
this protein, at all.
- So these are real crickets,
what's in here?
- There are crickets in there.
- There really are-
- [Man] It's just not his line.
- It's just not my line.
- Okay.
- I would have supported the product.
(laughter)
- That's what I'm talking about.
- Oh my God.
- Rianna to you,
thank you.
- Thank you, no to you.
To you.
- You are the bomb.
- You're the bomb.
(laughter)